Eh Squeezie , Mcfly et Carlito ont des enfants, Norman a un enfant, Amixem aussi, et toi ? C'est quand ? Ohlala mais attendez !
Écoutez, je reçois un nombre de messages incalculable de gens qui me disent eh squeezie à quand l'enfant toi aussi ?
Mais ehhh j'ai que 23 ans !
Ça se fait pas ce que vous me faites vous mettez une pression énorme sur un truc qui doit me pendre au nez dans au
moins sept ans, selon moi allez plutôt dire ça à Cyprien qui à 30 ans ou à Natoo qui en a 34, ou même à
Pierre Croce qui à 32 ans mais moi laissez moi tranquille !
Pourquoi je suis pas prêt avoir un enfant les amis déjà parce que, je trouve qu'ils sont démoniaques
ce sont des entités démoniaques je redoute les enfants j'ai peur des enfants ok ça peut être les êtres les plus mignons et cool tout
comme des êtres fourbes et pervers qui sont prêts à tout pour avoir ce qu'ils veulent j'ai beaucoup de mal avec
les enfants en général c'est même pas genre moi avoir un enfant c'est chaud c'est les enfants en général
j'ai du mal parce que je suis pas prêt à faire des concessions à accepter des choses à m'infliger du mal euhh
Rohh je me rend compte que j'ai une vision très triste de ça pour le moment mais je suis jeune putain c'est normal donc j'ai mis au
point un petit test ok nous allons aujourd'hui regarder des vidéos d'enfants
C'est un peu glauque dit comme ça oui ne vous en faites pas des vidéos d'enfants normal
normaux d'enfants normaux donc déjà quand on ne sait pas accorder normal c'est que ce n'est pas le moment d'avoir un enfant dans sa vie qui
font des petites actions qu'on a nous mêmes fait aussi quand on avait leur âge mais si vous êtes en âge d'avoir un enfant vous
supporterez la vue de ses actions ce qui est rarement mon cas mais bon
d'après-vous eh à quand l'enfant squeezie allez on enfile ce casque et on s'y colle ça va me mettre mal je le sais d'avance toute sa
vie il aura de la haine dans son coeur à cause de ce moment à cause d'un autre enfant évidemment
Oh nan
Regardez
Si ma fille fait ça mais qu'est ce que je fais
Trop de responsabilités
Au cachot, au cachot tout de suite
Comment vous faites pour cautionner ça ?
ou pour lui dire c'est pas bien ? ou pour mettre un pansement sur la plaie que ça aura créé dans le coeur de ce jeune
homme de quoi il est fait ce pansement hein
Oh nan, il a oh nan
Alors
déjà j'ai vraiment cru qu'il allait frapper son enfant c'est horrible pourquoi parce qu'à sa place je ne serais pas resté si calme même si
un objet tombe sur le bouton on off de mon pc je vais m'énerver contre l'objet je vais le casser vous voyez là on vient
de voir vraiment le pourquoi je ne veux pas d'enfant s'il fallait montrer une vidéo c'est celle là c'est vraiment celle là, la seule fois où
quelqu'un a éteint mon pc pendant que j'y jouais je me suis fait 20 points de suture à la main après il y'a un petit
côté mignon genre il veut l'attention de son père et il'a compris que quand il faisait ça il l'avait est-ce que ce père passe beaucoup trop
de temps devant les jeux vidéo d'ailleurs il a perdu son travail
entre temps et il n'arrive plus à subvenir aux besoins de sa famille donc voilà c'est une manière pour son fils déjà très intelligent de lui
faire comprendre eh oh ressaisis toi papa c'est très beau est ce que je me fais des films
peut-être mon frère a pris mon casque et les a remis comme si rien n'était ça a l'air d'être vraiment moi plus jeune
Comment elle sait ? Comment il peut savoir que le petit frère a pris les écouteurs
Ah il l'a cassé ? AHAHAHA
Ah c'est horrible, comment il peut se dire ça passe ce n'est pas moi il l'a pété à deux endroits
il a rafistolé un endroit sur deux il n'était pas loin du perfect ça aurait pu passer s'ils avaient pensé au deuxième c'est
génial c'est vous savez pourquoi ? J'ai une anecdote de moi qui a fait exactement la même chose étant plus jeune mais
Mais exactement pareil je jouais à quake sur le pc portable de mon père et je jouais et tout et je faisais que de perdre que de
me faire défoncer que de perdre comme maintenant en fait et là j'ai frappé comme ça là
sur le clavier du pc portable parce que j'ai rager et mec y'a une touche qui est partie
c'est bon mais qui est vraiment partie par la fenêtre comme ça avec ses petites jambes elle est partie elle a dit j'arrête je souffre
exactement comme cet enfant qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris la touche je l'ai remis j'ai fermé l'ordi et je l'ai rangé comme ça
tout en sachant que cet ordinateur portable était l'outil de travail de mon père qu'est ce qui s'est passé le lendemain
Ah bah j'ai été réveillé très tôt par mon père très très tôt
mon petit cousin badass a commandé 300 $ de jouets sans que ma tante et mon oncle le sachent
voici une photo du moment où tout le monde s'est rendu compte du truc
Regardez regardez elle est diabolique regardez je vais mettre cette vidéo dans la catégorie thread d'horreur je déconne pas alors c'est ça être
riche
voilà ce qu elle se dit sous le regard du livreur qui lui ne comprend rien mais nous on se prenait pour des délinquants quand
volé le téléphone de nos parents pour faire des codes allopass là pour se faire des kamas sur dofus mec regarde la nouvelle génération, la nouvelle
génération mec ils ont franchi un cap ils ont innové comme personne avant
Oh putain on est dans un shonen vous sentez là vous sentez ce qui va se passer il est bien plus puissant que moi et il
le sait mais je vais grandir je vais me dépasser et je me vengerai
Vous voyez là par exemple comment tu peux te dire y'a pas de soucis quand t'es parent je trouve que tu acceptes des trucs mais qui
pour moi sont choquants à l'heure actuelle moi le gamin qui a mis gratos la balle dans la tête je vais je lui court après déja
Je l'attrape comme ça par les aisselles et je lui dit : POURQUOI T'AS FAIT ÇA !!
QU'EST CE QUI T'A PRIS ? PLUS JAMAIS TU M'ENTENDS ? PLUS JAMAIS ÇA ! Pardon, dans une démarche bienveillante et sage bien entendu
Oh la vache
sauter sur la mercedes
de son papa quel plaisir mais il veut péter la voiture pour se venger ou il compte vraiment sur le capot pour l'aider à à
sauter plus haut comme un trampoline je veux comprendre aidez moi à comprendre à percer le mystère de l'enfance, cet enfant a besoin d'être
supervisé fin c'est à un mariage j'espère que la gaffe n'est pas énorme
Il en a rien à foutre c'est incroyable mais c'est touchant
y'a pas de graves répercussions c'est innocent il a vu un gros paquet de tissu il s'est dit "Je vais sauter dedans ça va amortir
la chute ça va être trop cool c'est mignon
oh la la qu'est ce qui se passe là ça veut pas dire je suis prêt à avoir un enfant rassurez moi un enfant frappe
au visage Shaq' pardon, Shaq' qui est un homme de 2 m 16 et qui pèse
147 kg et qui peut niquer à n'importe quel moment ta mère autant vous dire que cet enfant n'a peur de rien
Ce regard ça ne l'a pas du tout fait rire et il ne peut pas gronder le petit garçon car il est sur un plateau télé
et ça peut être mal vu car ce n'est pas son petit garçon quelle belle situation de merde putain
je là je m'enterre si c'est mon gosse je m'enterre c'est la honte c'est horrible je crois que je suis trop sensible au regard que
les gens me porteront au jugement en fait qu'ils auront sur moi par rapport à comment se comporten mon gosse plus tard c'est je trouve ça
doit être un truc très stressant quand t'es parent t'as vraiment peur qu'il te fasse honte ou qu'il se comporte pas correctement et du coup ça renvoie
le message aux gens du "Bah ouais il fait ça donc je m'en occupe pas comme il faut et mon éducation n'est pas bonne." Je pense moi
je me ferais matrixé par ce truc là je serai un fou je deviendrais fou il a essayé de sauter au dessus d'une flaque
d'eau tout en tenant maman je ne comprends pas ce titre
Aucune complicité entre cette personne et ses enfants je suis horrible de dire ça en tout cas y est on est face à un gros moment
d'incompréhension
soyons clairs oh nan elle s'est vraiment ramassé oh la pauvre et qu'est ce qu'il fout il vient l'engeuler et pourquoi il fait ça avec son bras ?
il l'accuse ? d'être responsable ? je comprends pas je n'ai rien compris à cette vidéo elle m'a rendu anxieux la suivante s'il vous plaît
Oh nan c'est la même mécanique que la première vidéo
celle qui fait mal celle où tu regrettes immédiatement d'avoir fait un enfant Oh nan il va se foirer il va tout il va tout péter
Ce père qui avait consacré probablement deux heures de son temps à mettre au point le parcours parfait de dominos et qui comptait donner le
plaisir du déclenchement de ce dernier à sa fille pour la combler de bonheur et de joie
Y'a un nombre de choses qui ne vont pas mec déjà est ce que c'est moi où est ce que cette arme est sept fois trop puissante
par rapport à l'âge de ces gamins mec ils ont un putain de gun à billes
automatique qui a l'air de tirer super fort et il tire sur la CAMÉRAAAAA
AHH les idiots je me souviens à l'époque j'avais acheté moi j'étais très très fan de de gun à billes
à l'époque et j'en avait acheté un à 15 euro dans un truc flingué un peu en cachette genre il est sorti un endroit bizarre du
magasin y'a vraiment une sorte de trafic cacher mais c'était un bolt ça veut dire qu'il fallait faire crac-crac avant de tirer
crac crac je suis une personne âgée ok c'est bon j'ai l'âge d'avoir un enfant c'est bon
Qu'est ce qu'il fait ?
C'est quoi cet adulte un peu bête dans un corps d'enfant rien n'est logique
ni la personne qui filme et qu'il laisse tout ça se passer sous ses yeux ni son comportement à lui ou alors c'est très logique
pour lui et moi en tant qu'adulte je ne comprends pas ce qu'il est en train de manigancer ah c'est sûrement ça d'ailleurs, le salaud
C'est vraiment malcolm le truc c'est touchant et naïf je trouve le fait que quand t'es tout petit ta seule défense c'est
t'enfoncer dans le mensonge à tout prix même s'il y'a toutes les preuves que tu as fait cette bêtise tu ne veux surtout pas l'avouer
et tu veux totalement le cacher comme le petit qui a pété le casque de sa grande soeur tout à l'heure
C'est mignon, oh je vais faire un enfant ce soir moi, ohhhhhh !
Ah vous voyez ? vous voyez ce visage là on l'a vu là c'est la fin de cette vidéo
foutez moi la paix pitié avec les enfants je ne veux pas d'enfant pour le moment et on fera une vidéo dans sept ans quand j'en
aurai un où je regarde cette vidéo là où je me dis oh lala comme j'ai changé ah j'étais nul avant ouhou
écoutez j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu et vous aura servi de leçon s'il vous plaît arrêtez de me dire eh à quand l'enfant
ça me met une pression que je ne dois pas avoir à mon âge
arrêtez par contre ce qui est ouf c'est que pour beaucoup d'entre vous on a vraiment grandi ensemble
et oui il y en a un qui regardent cette vidéo qui avaient 16 ans à l'époque quand ils regardaient mes vidéos quand j'avais
moi 17 ans et un jour j'aurais 30 et vous aurez 31 et ce jour là on
reviendra tous regarder cette vidéo là croyez-moi c'est ce qui va se passer en tout cas bravo à tous les parents du monde qui supportent
les bêtises de leurs enfants et qui le envoient tout l'amour du monde et qui leur offrent toutes les chances possibles pour réussir dans la
vie je trouve ça très beau ça j'avoue je peux être que touché par ça je trouve ça ouf
même quand je vois Mcfly et Carlito l'amour qu'ils envoient leurs enfants ça me touche mais je ne veux pas que ça ne me concerne pour
le moment ok la leçon est passé c'est pour vous cette vidéo et personne d'autre c'est vous la allez je vous laisse je veux pas d'enfants
Tu penses qu'ils ont compris le message que
je voulais pas d'enfants pour le moment